[jazz music]
[clears throat]
- Oh, honey, I am tired.
I am going to bed. Good night.
- Uh,
well...
[laughs]
- Is everything okay?
- Well, it's, uh...
It's just
that I was hoping that...
well, that we could...
and I...
I wanna make this clear.
I want to be straightforward.
I want to have--
- Okay. Uh, Luther?
Are you available to translate?
- Yes, ma'am.
- [clears throat]
I really was hoping we could
spend some time together.
- When was the last time
we had sex, woman?
Reelection night?
What does a brother
not named Bill Clinton
have to do to get some [bleep]
in this house?
- Well, you have been
very busy lately.
- Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
You know what?
If I could j...
Can we get your translator?
- Oh, yes, certainly.
Uh, Katendra?
- Yeah, honey?
- Could you please translate
"well, you have been
very busy lately"?
- Sure.
My [bleep] ain't
one of your limousines
that you can jump in and out
of whenever you feel like.
I don't see you all day,
then you want a booty call?
I need an emotional connection,
[bleep].
- Thought this was romantic.
- I'm [bleep] trying, bitch!
Can't you see?
I'm playing the romantic music.
I got the Pinot in the glasses.
What more do you want from me?
An engraved invitation
from my nuts?
- Maybe we should make a date.
- What am I supposed to do,
jump out of my clothes
every time
little Barry stands
at attention?
You ain't my commander in chief,
mother [bleep]
and my vagina ain't some cave
in the Middle East
you can fly
your heat-seeking missile
into whenever you feel like it.
- Well, I did mean to call you,
but I had meetings all day long.
- I'm dealing with these
mother [bleep] Republicans,
hearing "no, no, no"
all day long.
Then I come home,
and you're not gonna let me
get my jam on up in here?
- Well, you know,
I have had a busy day too.
- You act like I ain't got
nothing else to do, [bleep].
I got these obese mother [bleep]
on my ass 24/7.
What's more important...
you getting your wick dipped
or some eight-year-old fat-ass
collapsing in his bunk bed?
- Okay.
- You seem to be forgetting
job number one.
You are my secretary
of [bleep] bitch!
Get to work!
- You.
[chuckles]
[moaning]
- Luther? Katendra?
- Yes, sir.
- We'll...
we'll take it from here.
- Absolutely, yes, sir.
- Yes, ma'am.
- Thank you.
- Good night. Good night, ma'am.
- [laughs]
- Come here.
- [chuckles]
Oh, this feels good.
- Um, Mom? Dad?
I know you already said
that I can't go,
but can I please go
to the party tonight?
- Malia, use your translator.
- If you don't let me go
to this party,
I will get a tattoo on my face.
- Have fun.
[soul music]